for years an underground war has raged
for dominance over the small town of
Fraser Park between two clans the two
four eight from the north word that's my
bro talk from the [ __ ] flow up
and the two four five from the South
musta l-dopa he's [ __ ] double serious
tonight
shit's getting hot the battle for the
AFP has only just begun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Joe's death wasn't your fault
it was his he wasn't expecting the
unexpected four five has taken over
further
he's got even more street cred now in
trouble yeah well now you got double
trouble [ __ ] either lasted it to four
hey we need your help
can't take out LW this [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
alone that's the beat again hey over
here
I challenge you to a beat up my Buster
[ __ ] novelist [ __ ]
Saturday night we have the foundation
and we gonna sell their [ __ ] a wild one
three rounds beat the revelation mad
[ __ ] the challenges up in this
[ __ ] Jethro now is the time
[Music]
[ __ ] up out of my face with that [ __ ]
let's try put your ass with your bowl
blatant cone down man oh is that [ __ ]
yeah I hope you ready for this [ __ ]
cranberry juice go dance with your mind
you've got to get [ __ ] this
[Music]